welcome back to cbs mornings as
president biden travels to belgium to
meet with nato members he says the
alliance is more united today than ever
before the reason vladimir putin this
morning chief washington correspondent
that's major garrett looks at the
history of nato and its many many
challenges over the decades he's at the
white house major i'm thinking a lot of
people could use a little history lesson
right about now you are the perfect
person for that good morning to you good
morning gail good morning everyone
president biden leaves for brussels this
morning knowing nato has never faced a
test like this a hot war in europe with
terrifying conventional weapons and the
possibility of worse nuclear biological
chemical weapons now nato is not
defending a member country but it has
grown unified in the minds of some
surprisingly unified in defense of
everything this alliance was created to
preserve
on april 4 1949 the north atlantic
treaty was signed nato grew out of world
war ii a defensive alliance to shield
western europe from the soviet union the
treaty members realized that real peace
is more than an absence of war
america and europe also wanted to
contain germany the aggressor nation in
both world wars the unofficial purpose
as it was quietly rumored at the time
was to keep the soviets out to keep the
americans in and to keep the germans
down in the late 40s the soviets
controlled east germany marking the
beginning of the cold war and nato's
formation the united states together
with our allies will defend every inch
of nato territory the key to nato is
article five an attack on one member
nation is an attack on the alliance and
all nations must respond in common
defense
that kept the peace for decades
in 1979 when the soviets invaded
afghanistan nato deployed nuclear
missiles as a deterrent when the berlin
wall fell in 1989 germany reunified and
pan-european peace seemed achievable
then came 911 a new kind of war nato
came to america's defense invoking
article 5 for the first time with nato
forces joining the u.s in afghanistan
for the next 20 years this was an act of
great friendship
in a time of great need in 2004 nato
added seven former soviet client states
and has gradually expanded since then to
its current size of 30 member nations
this expansion alarmed and infuriated
vladimir putin who saw nato a defensive
alliance as a military and political
rival one that might deprive russia of
global prominence i think it was
absolutely the right decision to expand
kay bailey hutchinson was u.s ambassador
to nato during the trump administration
if we hadn't gone
[Music]
out
and and brought those former soviet uh
satellite countries in with us
i think they'd be the ones that would be
invaded right now while it expanded the
alliance drifted member nations declined
to meet defense spending requirements an
issue pressed by the obama
administration if we've got collective
defense it means that everybody's got to
chip in and amplified by president trump
they will have to pay more frankly
they're going to have to pay more they
didn't like the tone that president
trump used of course but they never ever
said one time that they didn't know they
had to do more trump says he helped
revive the alliance though critics said
threatening to pull out of it did the
opposite
nato was talked off and on of adding
ukraine but never did
that's why nato did not intervene when
putin took crimea in 2014 and isn't
fighting russia now
this war is now about russia taking
control of all of ukraine if it can if
that happens of course ukraine would
never become a part of nato as we've
seen ukraine is fighting for its very
survival and its future and if it
prevails it may not need or want common
defense protection or it may want it
more than ever either way nato is not
far from the bloody center of this
conflict guys
you know major i always love a history
lesson from you and as you know general
dwight eisenhower was the first supreme
allied commander and he said in a speech
in 1957 we will in freedom pay any price
necessary to preserve freedom is nato
still willing to do that
it appears that it is and there's one
really important part of this process
that reunification of germany when
germany reunified then secretary of
state james baker said to mikhail
gorbachev if you let germany reunify on
our terms we won't expand nato one inch
to the east mikhail goberchov said okay
that's what putin seizes upon that was
an informal agreement the actual treaty
that did that though said nato could
expand so putin fixates on that informal
process ignores the actual treaty itself
major thank you always the history
lesson when you come on the show